o professor josé mauro será de lopes
costumava citar uma pesquisa canadense
que diz que o médico interrompe o
paciente média 18 segundos depois que
ele começa a falar nesse sentido eu acho
que talvez a gente precise mudar o nome
do pedex para o resgate do bem escutar
porque bem escutar é bem cuidar e
cuidará revolucionário assim como
revolucionário para mim estar aqui no
meio dessa dessas pessoas todas dessa
platéia
o meu ofício é de 18 anos enquanto
médico de família e comunidade é muito
mais na escuta do que na fala e quando
se fala em uma fala restrita uma fala
poucas pessoas uma fala para duas ou
três pessoas no ambiente muito mais
íntimo e obviamente que essa platéia é
não não ele não me dá a possibilidade
disso desse diálogo tentar olhar pra
vocês pensando numa conversa pensando
num diálogo mas certamente que isso é
revolucionário pra mim também um grande
desafio e nesse grande desafio vocês
viram que repetiu a palavra revolução
pelo menos duas vezes porque eu acredito
nela acredito que quer que as revoluções
são necessárias não necessariamente
essas revoluções de conquista de poderes
ou conquista de territórios mas as
nossas pequenas revoluções cotidianas as
que se fazem dentro da casa da gente que
é um espaço mais sagrado que a gente tem
para cada revolução existe obviamente um
herói uma heroína que também nem sempre
usam capa que nem sempre usam máscara
que nem sempre o vôo mas que estão
caminhando de forma a no nosso cotidiano
como anônimas é um pouco dessas pessoas
e desses heróis e as suas heroínas que
eu queria falar um pouco pra vocês hoje
um pouco das histórias dessas pessoas é
revolucionário quando a menina do estado
islâmico resolve por exemplo estudar que
é uma coisa simples é revolucionário
quando a menina de 15 anos da periferia
decide ter um filho ou quando o filho
decide gostar de um outro rapaz são
revoluções evoluções cotidianas são
essas que se fazem que não se nos que
nos constitui e vou falar primeiro então
dessa pessoa que era mito miramar da
silva e não é
to falando dele é um agente comunitário
de saúde
ele é das profissões mais especiais que
existem na atenção primária à saúde ele
é o elo entre a comunidade e os serviços
de atenção primária à saúde além de
fazer educação e saúde de fazer
visitação domiciliar de cuidar das
pessoas
ele tem uma outra atividade ele faz suas
casinhas de cachorro
ele reúne todo material reciclado que
ele tem com a ajuda de funcionários com
a ajuda da comunidade ele faz essas
casinhas e uma delas inclusive é
geminada como ele diz geminada porque é
o que a comunidade é hoje um loteamento
ele ele compara esse loteamento a outra
pessoa com quem eu vou falar pra vocês é
a ângela
eu digo que ângela é boleira de família
e comunidade é a boleira da comunidade e
ângela ela acompanha famílias tanto
quanto nós acompanhamos porque ela faz o
bolo do nascimento ela faz o bolo
batizado ela faz o bolo dos 15 anos e
ela tem uma história muito interessante
o primeiro livro de receitas da ângela
foi na verdade ela juntou uma série de
pacotes de açúcar é uma marca conhecida
de açúcar e ela fez a troca por um livro
de receitas
o outro livro de receitas que ângela tem
é um livro que foi doado por mulheres um
galpão de separação de lixo da
comunidade em que ela trabalhava e que
ela vendia salgadinhos e docinhos na
porta desse galpão de reciclagem então
ela tem esses dois cadernos de receitas
dos dois livros de receita
depois ela fez vários cadernos de
receita como provavelmente as nossas
mães e as nossas avós fazem milhares de
cadernos de receitas mas não são
quaisquer caderno de receitas porque o
que ela faz os cabelos de receita é
também a notar quando ela faz as
receitas o dia 11 dia chuvoso se o dia
tem sol se ela está feliz se ela está
triste e na verdade os cadernos de
receita dela são também pequenos diários
em um caderno dela é muito especial aqui
são os bolos da ângela e aqui azul mar
azul mar é extremamente especial
ela resignifica para todos nós a palavra
lixo porque foi disso que ela viveu
durante toda a parte da vida dela e
criou os filhos de forma muito digna
carregando carrinho como a gente diz que
esse instrumento com duas rodas que
parece uma charrete que as pessoas
colocam o material reciclado coletado da
rua e leva para suas casas e fazem a
separação do lixo o que aconteceu com a
sun mar depois de ter feito tudo isso
ela depois ela virou uma artesã e aí ela
usa as miçangas e por vocês podem
encontrar a somar e muitas feiras de
economia popular solidária no grupo de
artesãs que tem na unidade de saúde
e certamente comprovada a arte da somar
eu fico pensando nas miçangas do avião
da azul marido quanto ela une me lembro
do livro dome acordo que o fio das
missangas e o filme adulto ele diz que
cada missang é uma história que existe
um fio condutor e o fio condutor para
essas pessoas é o fato de elas terem
vivido na vila dique e de terem sido
removidas para o porto novo
é um fio condutor extremamente
importante a gente contar a vila dique é
uma área de ocupação irregular e há 40
anos pessoas de vários lugares do estado
do rio grande do sul principalmente no
interior
ambos vieram morar na vila dique
extremamente vulnerável pobre na área
com as habitações precárias mas as
pessoas de forma muito digna
conquistaram família conquistaram
aparelhos sociais como por exemplo uma
escola uma unidade de saúde que aqui o
trabalho com muito orgulho e uma creche
um galpão de reciclagem uma padaria
comunitária essas pessoas essas mães o
clube de mães margarida alves foi
responsável por isso
por uma série de questões e de discursos
o primeiro discurso o discurso da
dignidade da moradia o segundo discurso
que é o discurso da legitimidade desse
território eo terceiro discurso que eu
entendo que é o mais importante
vamos ter um mega evento teremos uma
copa de 2014 essas pessoas começaram a
ser removidas essas emoções ainda não
terminaram como ainda não terminaram
muitas obras da copa do mundo mas
certamente essas pessoas
nos trazem essas questões todos os dias
nas consultas médicas nas consultas com
a enfermagem todas as consultas
isso enquanto motivo de sofrimento
enquanto motivo de medo mas também
motivo de esperança porque não existe
unanimidade não existe nada que seja bom
ou ruim
as pessoas fazem suas escolhas e muitas
delas não podem fazer essas escolhas e
essas pessoas vinham trazendo isso pra
gente me lembro de uma paciente que
disse que a china tinha chegado na vila
dia que tinha uma não tinha árvore ela
plantou uma árvore e no momento que ela
plantou a vieram os passarinhos e ela
tinha muito claro que os passarinhos em
cantar pra elas que os passarinhos vem
cantar pra mim eles estão gratos porque
eu vim implantei essa água e nesse
sentido é como é que vai ser agora como
é que eu vou sair daqui como é que vão
ficar essas pacientes passarinhos
a gente escutou tudo isso ea gente
entendeu que isso tinha que essa escuta
tinha que ter um direcionamento
a gente entende que isso tem a ver com
saúde sim apesar de vocês estarem se
perguntando o que isso tem a ver com
saúde porque a saúde não é mera ausência
de doença saúde também essa
possibilidade de moradia digna
também de uma emoção digna e dialogada e
dessa escuta desse sofrimento das
pessoas ea partir disso então a gente
criou o projeto memórias da vila dique e
o projeto memórias da vila dique ele era
extremamente simples
a idéia dele é reunir as pessoas numa
roda e fazer com que essas pessoas a
partir de um muro de chocolate e de 1 de
maio de um chá feito com as ervas do
quintal das pessoas fotos imagens e
objetos que lembrassem a vila dique e
que elas pudessem contar um pouco das
suas trajetórias de onde elas vieram
como elas se constituíram naquele espaço
criaram as suas famílias que elas
fizeram ea partir disso a gente criou
teve uma série de produtos um desses
produtos é o livro memórias da vila
dique também que foi lançado no salão de
atos da universidade federal do rio
grande do sul foi uma parceria do grupo
hospitalar conceição ea universidade na
pessoa da professora carmem exigiu e nós
tivemos nesse livro tivemos um médio
traje um curta metragem e diversos
espaços culturais dessas pessoas
transitaram eu não preciso dizer pra
vocês o quanto foi importante para essas
pessoas estarem nesses espaços falando
das suas histórias autografando os
livros
isso foi extremamente importante para
elas no entanto algo sucedeu e
obviamente que o passado é muito
importante ele ressignifica e direciona
o futuro ter recebido o presente gestão
no futuro
porém essas pessoas na remoção elas
tiveram que enfrentar outros desafios e
esses desafios que pra gente são banais
para elas não era uma coisa banal como
por exemplo um cep o endereço eo
endereço é muito importante é conter o
comprovante de endereço que se abra uma
conta no banco é com comprovante de
endereço que você matricular seu filho
na escola o que você recebe uma
geladeira um televisor na sua casa
isso parece uma luta banal mas não é uma
luta banal e eles tiveram que lutará até
por ter um endereço em direção à questão
de cidadania é uma questão de saúde
também ea partir disso essas pessoas
também começaram a ressignificar o seu
território e nessa ressignificação do
território a horta o comentário do clube
de mães margarida alves e o nosso e é o
nosso incentivo ea nossa ideia de que de
fato esse projeto não fazia mais sentido
sem memória da vila dique e junto com a
comunidade a gente denominou ele de
minha nova rua porque de fato é o que a
gente tinha uma nova rua ou novas ruas
ou novas realidades e novas lutas e se o
clube de mães e ainda tivemos ainda a
reabilitação e revitalização dos espaços
públicos com plantio de mudas com
enfeite e aqui tem mais muito
interessante que dessa criança brincando
com uma retroescavadeira de brinquedo
essa retroescavadeira
no passado la nas remoções ela é de uma
extrema violência porque no momento que
as pessoas estavam saindo de casa a
retroescavadeira passava por cima das
casas para que elas não fossem retomadas
por outras pessoas então as pessoas
estavam saindo e estavam sendo as casas
estavam sendo destruídas
e aqui ela ela se constitui em uma
construção uma coisa
são de brincadeira uma construção de
crianças mas é uma construção
temos também aqui essa outra
ressignificação por parte dos meninos da
comunidade que começaram até o skate
para poder do povo às ruas e também está
se movimentando de um outro jeito
inicialmente ele se autodenominaram a
fênix porque renascido das cinzas e eles
não ficaram somente nesse território
eles também saíram por outros espaços
consagrados do skate em porto alegre
aqui a praça da matriz e isso que a
gente chama de direito à cidade que o
direito que às vezes as periferias não
tem que sair do seu território e poder
transitar na cidade nos espaços de lazer
e de poder trocar socialmente com outros
meninos de outros lugares
esses dois projetos tanto o da horta
comunitária quanto do skate a gente viu
que o edital do ministério da saúde e
ele foi o primeiro prêmio victor valla
de educação popular em saúde na
categoria narrativas com o valor do
prêmio que o confesso para vocês é bem
inferior do que qualquer número que está
sendo colocado nos telejornais em
relação às propinas
a gente fez um campeonato de skate em
que a gente dê um skate para cada menino
porque a gente tem de que todos são
campeões são fênix e são todos campeões
eu acho que essa modificação do nome
fala muito dessa modificação também que
a gente tem que seguir na comunidade e
nas comunidades com as quais a gente
trabalha as comunidades se modificam nós
modificamos juntamente com elas ea gente
tem que aprender a fazer essas escutas
muito especialmente eu trago essas mãos
um pouquinho sujas aqui do menino que
pintou os pneus conosco para falar um
pouco de novo de poesia que essa coisa
de a gente ter duas mãos o sentimento do
mundo que nem jogou
eu acho que é um pouco isso que é o
nosso trabalho como médico de família e
comunidade
a gente não acha que isso é a única
coisa existem muitas escolhas todas elas
são muito especiais
mas o que a gente entende que as pessoas
e quando passam os residentes por nós e
para os estudantes do 6º ano o que a
gente costuma dizer que eles não
precisam fazer suas escolhas mas eles
precisam saber de onde é que as pessoas
vem
as pessoas vão à qual é a história que
as pessoas têm para contar isso sim isso
é necessário para todas as
especialidades médicas e nesse sentido
obviamente que eu não tô aqui pra falar
em nome dessas pessoas e seria injusto
com as histórias delas também não tô
aqui pra falar em nome de todos os
médicos de família e comunidade que
vivem em contextos talvez mais precários
e mais vulneráveis com mais desafios do
que os que a gente vive
são pessoas que estão por exemplo no
sertão nordestino que estão trabalhando
com população de rua que trabalham em
área de difícil acesso em favela não
pacificada nos diversos contextos todos
eles extremamente área de trabalho ea
gente convive e tem o privilégio de
conviver com essas mudanças e com esse
lugar nesse lugar que eu penso que é o
lugar mais sagrado que a gente pode
conviver que a casa da gente é onde a
gente se constitui em um agente é e vai
sendo durante a vida e eu vou lembrar
agora por último de um poema de de
colégio de uma pessoa que tem o seu nome
engraçado de judas grogotó que se chama
o herói e esse poema ele diz mais ou
menos assim ele na verdade um diálogo
entre o pai o filho em que o filho
pergunta pro pai o que é seu herói
porque ele também é um ser o herói
ele também mas ele quer ser o herói se
ter que matar as pessoas e tem que
conquistar continentes e ele pergunta
principai obviamente que eu não vou me
lembrar da da poesia em cima desse pai
que é um agricultor que está num
contexto de labuta cotidiana esse pai
nada tem a dizer
ele nada tem a explicar ele simplesmente
pega uma peneira e saiu a semear e eu
penso que quando a gente trabalhou na
vila dique no porto novo em qualquer
outra periferia
quando a gente pergunta às pessoas das
histórias delas elas também nem sempre
sabem dizer nem sempre sabem explicar
ela simplesmente pega uma peneira e
saias emea
muito obrigada